♪ ♪
>> Sean: EVEN MORE DISASTROUS
BEHAVIOR FROM NEW YORK CITY
OFFICIALS.
GET THIS, NEW YORK CITY FAILED
HEALTH COMMISSIONER REPORTEDLY
BLEW OFF NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST FOR SURGICAL
MASKS, SAYING I DON’T GIVE TWO
RATS ASSES ABOUT YOUR COPS.
PRETTY DESPICABLE.
RUDY GIULIANI, THE COPS WERE
ASKING FOR THE MASKS BECAUSE
THEY WERE GETTING SICK,
MR. MAYOR.
HOW DOES THIS GUY STILL HAVE A
JOB TONIGHT?
>> IT’S A WOMAN, AND ONLY
BECAUSE SHE REFLECTS THE MAYOR’S
ATTITUDE.
THERE’S NOBODY IN THIS CITY AND
CERTAINLY NO POLICE OFFICER THAT
WOULD EXPECT THAT THAT IS
DE BLASIO’S ATTITUDE.
HE’S BEEN AGAINST THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SINCE THE DAY HE
WANTED OFFICE.
THEY TURNED THEIR BACK ON HIM
BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED DURING THE MURDER OF
DETECTIVE RAMOS.
HE’S NEVER REALLY SPOKEN UP FOR
THEM.
HE WASN’T THERE FOR THEM NOW AND
GET THEM THE HELP AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED.
OVER 4,000 ARE SICK, 40 PLUSES
HAVE DIED ALREADY OR ARE NEAR
DEATH.
LOOK, IF YOU DON’T UNDERSTAND AS
THE MAYOR HOW TO GET THE SUPPORT
OF YOUR POLICE DEPARTMENT, YOU
SHOULD RESIGN.
IT’S THE MOST IMPORTANT AGENCY
THAT YOU HAVE.
IT’S THE ONE THAT KEEPS PEOPLE
ALIVE AND IF YOU’RE THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY, YOU GET A
BLESSING OF GOD BECAUSE YOU’VE
GOT THE BEST POLICE DEPARTMENT
IN THE WORLD.
I HAD A PERFORMATIVE FIT AND I
HAD THREE GREAT COMMISSIONERS,
BUT MOST OF ALL HE HAD AN
UNBELIEVABLE GROUP OF 40,000
POLICE OFFICERS, ABOUT 99.9% OF
WHOM ARE THE BEST IN THE COUNTRY
AND THE WORLD.
SO IF YOU TURN THEM OFF, YOU’RE
NOT MEANT TO BE MAYOR.
IT SHOULD BE SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON’T KNOW, MAYBE, YOU KNOW --
STAY WHERE YOU WENT ON YOUR
HONEYMOON, de BLASIO.
>> Sean: de BLASIO DIDN’T
BUY THE 10,000 VENTILATORS HIS
OWN HEALTH FORCE THAT HE NEEDED.
THE OTHER HE HAD HE AUCTIONED
OFF, WE DON’T KNOW WHO TO.
IN MARCH 2ND THROUGH FIFTH HE
WAS SAYING, GO OUT ON THE TOWN,
HERE ARE MY RECOMMENDATIONS.
MARCH 10TH HE WAS SAYING THE
RISK IS STILL VERY LOW.
OKAY, A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT IT
WRONG.
>> I SHOULDN’T LAUGH, IT’S A
DISASTER.
HE GOT IT WRONG BY TWO OR THREE
MORE WEEKS THAN ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE BASICALLY HE DOESN’T GO
TO WORK.
I MEAN, THE GUY COMES IN LATE,
WELL-KNOWN STORY.
DOESN’T REALLY PAY ATTENTION,
GETS AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PROTECTS
THEM.
"THE POST" COVERS IT SOMEWHAT.
THEY ACTUALLY DON’T COVER IT THE
WAY THEY SHOULD.
HE’S BEEN A DISASTER OF A MAYOR.
I’VE A RADIO SHOW NOW, SPECIAL
ON CORONAVIRUS AND I CHALLENGE
PEOPLE TO DEFEND HIM.
I SAY, SOMEBODY CALL ME UP AND
DEFEND HIM.
I CAN’T FIND A DEMOCRAT IN THIS
CITY THAT DEFENDS HIM.
MY DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS WHO ARE
ANGRY AT ME FOR SUPPORTING TRUMP
AND REPRESENTING TRUMP, I WILL
SAY TO THEM, WHAT ABOUT
DE BLASIO?
THEY WILL SAY, LET’S TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE.
NOBODY DEFENDS IMPURITY AS NO
ONE -- I’VE NEVER SEEN
THIS BEFORE.
AND IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING THAT
YOU SHOULD UNDERSTAND.
WE YOU SELECT FOR MAJOR PUBLIC
OFFICE AS A MATTER OF LIFE AND
DEATH.
THIS HEALTH COMMISSIONER, I
HAVEN’T SEEN HER FOR THIS ENTIRE
PANDEMIC.
MY HEALTH COMMISSIONER DURING
WEST NILE VIRUS AND ANTHRAX AND
9/11 WAS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THIS IS THE FIRST APPEARANCE.
CONDEMNING THE POLICE.
SAYONARA, GONE.
DON!